big TV newsroom the weekend to show you
were right there in the middle of all of
them yes indeed it was all Paley all the
time such a fun Television Festival and
this one honored a lot of our favorite
TV show starting with CBS's mom now I'm
moderated you know we'll get to that but
first on Affairs opens up about her
split from Chris Pratt
we had an unbelievable marriage yeah and
we have a great friendship now we love
our son to death and and I'm really
proud of that Anna is uncensored
speaking on Dax Shepards armchair expert
podcast the to get brutally honest about
how their relationships in real life
aren't what you see on social media we
intentionally cultivated the idea of
like look at this beautiful family but
of course just like anything on social
media you don't post like Chris's at a
hotel tonight
we've been going to couples therapy
since day one
you know she's got depression as on
pills I'm a recovering alcoholic I have
both things
what is totally legit though is honest
love for her son yeah he is just such a
loving funny cuddly little boy if you
know will crawl into bed with me in the
morning and he gets all stinky breath
she spent the night out with her mom
cast including Allison Janney we wanted
to know has she become a total diva
since winning her Oscar yeah pretty much
I'm intolerable I demand you know
bring me everything and help me memorize
my lines actually she's totally kidding
in fact they celebrate by doing the
crazy dance listen this is what happens
in between sort of scene setups Alison
and I you know get obnoxious well I'm
probably I'm the obnoxious one Alison is
always classy and amazing wanting makes
the biggest fool out of myself
[Music]